يخيم
الحزن والخسارة على نطاق لا يسبر غوره.
عدد القتلى في غزة وعدد
الجرحى المدنيين يتزايد مع كل
غارة جوية على مخيم الهات للاجئين. الرجال يحفرون
بأيديهم العارية يائسين
لإنقاذ أحبائهم من تحت
الأنقاض فيما كان منازلهم في السابق.
يبدأ بسرد أسماء
الأطفال الذين قُتلوا في هذه
الغارة الأخيرة، ومن بينهم ابنة أخته التي كان
عمرها بضعة أشهر فقط، وهي الآن واحدة من بين أكثر
من 440 طفلاً تقول وزارة الصحة في غزة
إنهم قتلوا في غارة جوية إسرائيلية حتى الآن،
وتقول إسرائيل إنها  يضرب
أهدافًا لحماس لكن السلطات هنا تقول إن
المرافق الطبية والمدارس والمناطق السكنية
قد
تأثرت، وقال جيراننا إن
الإسرائيليين اتصلوا وطلبوا منهم
إخلاء المنطقة المحيطة بمنزلنا، لذلك
جئنا لنقيم مع أقاربنا هنا في
النبيل، لكن التالي يقول:  في الصباح عندما
استيقظنا للصلاة فجرا، وقعت الغارة الجوية
ولم يكن هناك أي
إنذار. قطاع غزة المكتظ بالسكان
والذي يخضع
لحصار بري وبحري وجوي إسرائيلي منذ عام 2007، يسكنه
أكثر من مليوني شخص، حوالي 47٪
منهم من الأطفال.  يضطر الكثيرون الآن إلى
اللجوء إلى مدارس تابعة للأمم المتحدة مثل هذه،
لكن المدنيين هنا يواجهون الآن أيضًا
ما وصفته الحكومة الإسرائيلية
بالحصار الكامل على
غزة. لا يوجد ماء نشربه ولا
ماء نغتسل به حتى نتمكن من الاحتماء به.
يمكننا أن نصلي، ويقولون إنهم قصفوا
مدارسنا، وقد قُتل العديد من الأشخاص،
وهذا ليس عدلاً للأطفال مثلنا، لماذا
يحدث هذا
لنا؟ الحياة تحت الحصار هي كل ما
عرفه أطفال غزة منذ
بعض الأشخاص الذين يبلغون من العمر 13 عامًا.  نادين العجوز، من الصعب
أن أتخيل مستقبلًا أبعد من هذا
الصراع الذي لا هوادة فيه،
كانت الليالي القليلة الماضية أسوأ
ليلتين عشتهما في حياتي، هذا
لا أعيشه، هذا موجود، لسنا
موجودين، لا نخطط
لرحلتنا  بعد الآن، نحن نحاول فقط
البقاء على قيد الحياة، ولكن البقاء على قيد الحياة في غزة أصبح
أكثر صعوبة يوما بعد يوم، حيث
يتدهور الوضع الإنساني بسرعة، وبينما أدانت الأمم المتحدة
ما وصفته
بالحصار الإسرائيلي غير القانوني على غزة
والطبيعة العشوائية للحصار الإسرائيلي.
الضربات الجوية هناك أمل ضئيل في أن
تنتهي سفك الدماء
هنا شمال شرق
سي إن إن